okay everyone it has been a big week in
news for the DCE you over at Warner
Brothers so to keep you all from having
to go back here and look around across
several different websites for all this
info we thought we'd break down all the
updates that you need to know cool you
with us awesome okay first the biggest
news is that the upcoming Batman solo
film directed by Matt Reeves which still
technically has Ben Affleck attached
even though he'll probably be replaced
Jake Gyllenhaal will see will not go
into production until 2019 we probably
won't even see any film in theaters
until 2020 at the earliest meanwhile the
Warner Brothers Studio has three DC
movies that are being shot in 2018 hmm
Shazam the Wonder Woman's sequel
remember that as Kristen Wiig recently
cast as a fill-in cheetah and then the
Todd Phillips joke her origin movie
which sounds like it will feature the
Joker as a failed
80s comedian it's amazing
what doesn't kill you make you stranger
okay and we mentioned Shazam stars asher
angel he's playing Billy Batson and
Zachary Levi claimed Sam took a break
from shooting to do a Facebook live
stream this week where Levi described
the movie as Superman meets big which if
you know the characters it is a good
description of how that was good for
kids you think uh I think so that's what
they were trying to say this is a
family-friendly fun light-hearted
costume hey it's great he looks like an
action figure they blew up if he doesn't
talk like this but his Shazam I'll be
really upset okay well guys the closest
big event on the DC calendars of course
Aquaman we should be gained a trailer
for it
very soon perhaps by the time actually
you're watching this video there's
already a trailer port and then future
me is busy working on it in my dark room
and deflate they're losing my mind but
keep an eye out for that trailer test
audiences apparently according to rumors
been coming at us we'll be loving it
well you know maybe DC's just realizing
that their solo movies like Wonder Woman
tend to be easier to pull off than these
big team events like just like in
Suicide Squad
surprisingly we actually learned this
week that Justice League has been the
lowest-grossing DCE movie so far
now analysts are pointing to the damage
that movies like Batman Superman Suicide
Squad might have done to the franchise
brand you know may have it led some fans
to prematurely writing off justice
league unfairly but again it's not all
doom and gloom you know Wonder Woman has
the highest-grossing DC movie box office
total she's getting a sequel and Warner
seems to be moving more towards like
solo films like that was what was Shazam
and an Aquaman and flash point you know
what do you guys most excited about what
the future of DC Shazam is a fun one
have fun just have fun with the movie
make it a comedy just don't make it
cringe-worthy Shazam's a fun idea it's a
kid who gives me a superhero have fun
with that idea it's like you can get
like elements of Iron Giant in there a
little bit then he gets to hang out with
like this bigger character the the
character they're gonna pick for this is
basically a kid who's hurt a lot but he
gets he has the choice to actually be
better and also he gets to share that
power with all of his foster siblings
too and so they all get to be other
versions of Shazam as well which is cool
let us know what you are most looking
forward to with these DC movies a Wonder
Woman Aquaman the Joker or dream movie
we've done other videos about that
hopefully a Batman movie that'll come
out in a couple years we do fan casting
for The New Yorker I think we did talk
about that right we was walking Phoenix
as one being rumored mmm I mean he's up
for everything he's up for everything
they're always like a walking fix maybe
for Doctor Strange if like Iron Man or
something's like he's not gonna or hope
he was up for that for a second it was
like yes he was gonna be an Avenger i
sat on it pretty big dump on it okay
well guys hey comment down below
remember to subscribe to new rock stars
for all of our DC coverage thanks guys